thank you thank you Tara good evening
and welcome to the strategy and
resources committee meeting held on the
25th of
January uh my name is councelor Mark
darham and I'm the chairperson of this
committee members we are streaming this
meeting live as well as recording by
being present in the meeting you are
giving your consent being recorded and
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak and
other than invite you at the appropriate
time can I ask members to avoid
approaching the top table as this might
cause interference uh with the cameras
and the live stream and please note the
YouTube live stream sound recording is
dependent on the correct use of the
microphones therefore can ask when
invited to speak you remember to turn on
can we Sorry members thank you uh
therefore can ask that when invited to
speak you remember to turn on your
microphone turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible thank you
next item is apologies for absence I
don't believe we have any Tara do we no
chairman everybody is here yeah that's
excellent excellent all here and on time
uh item three minutes it's recommended
the minutes of the meeting held on the
23rd of November 2023 to be found on
pages 5 to 30 are approved as a true and
accurate record I so move do I have a
seconder councelor Thompson got in first
everybody
happy councelor Fluker yes excellent
thank
you sorry sorry um chair could I just be
noted as being in attendance uh you are
thank you councel Lagan is in attendance
uh
Tara uh so we agree those minutes by
Ascent thank thank you very much indeed
uh item four Declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interests and non-reg
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
9 and appendix B of the code of conduct
for members and members you are reminded
that you are also required to disclose
any such interest as soon as you become
aware should the need arise through the
meeting item five is public
participation but I understand we have
no public speakers is that correct Tara
that's correct chair no public speakers
thank you very much that moves us on to
item six which is the council tax
support scheme report and miss
Lucas thank you chair um yeah this is
the um proposed council tax support
scheme for the year
20242 um members should note that
following the abolition of the National
Council tax benefits scheme in
2013 um local authorities were required
to put in place um local council tax
support schemes um and such a scheme was
approved by this Council in
2012 um since that date the scheme has
remained substantially unchanged um for
in subsequent years and the current
scheme reflects um the council's
decision to deliver a longterm
sustainable scheme um based on the
principle of cost neutrality um and it
there's only minimal changes that are
proposed to be introduced to this scheme
um in order to ensure that it reflects
National legislative
changes um so the schemes um
costs um are projected as I say to
remain sustainable for the year 2024 25
and additional support and advice
continues to be provided to customers
who have difficulty in paying um
including through the provision of a
hardship scheme which is part funded by
six County Council which is um proposed
to continue into
20242 and the framework for that is
found at appendix 2 um there's also a
discretionary reduction provision um
which again is appended to to the report
at appendix three which members are
asked to approve um the head of Revenue
and benefits Michelle is on the line as
well if there's any more specific
technical questions about the nature of
the report thank you chair thank you uh
thank you very much members we have a
number of recommendations have you are
there any questions for the officers
please this is fairly straightforward
it's an annual
thing nobody is showing that they wish
to You've Got Away very lightly Michelle
um nobody is showing so members we have
uh five
recommendations uh I don't need to read
through them you've all read them you
have them in front of you can we take
them on block yes and do we have Ascent
please or all agreed thank you very much
indeed chairman just to remind members
that that is a recommendation to councel
it is a recommendation to council yeah
okay thank you very much
okay next item on the agenda
is uh item seven business rting council
tax discretionary policies Miss Lucas
again this is Pages 197 to
250 thank you chair um so the purpose of
this report is for members to consider
the updated discretionary non-domestic
rate relief scheme which is found at
appendix one to the report which updates
and replaces the existing policy to
reflect changes announced by central
government um it's also for members to
consider the updated empty homes and
second homes premium policy which is
found at appendix 2 which again updates
and replaces the existing policy to
reflect changes previously endorsed by
members and now legislated for by
central
government um the government has
announced that eligible rate payers will
receive 75% retail hospitality and
Leisure re Leisure relief on their
business rates bills for the year
20242 um and the uh policy at appendix
one provides for the granting of those
reliefs in in line with the published
guidelines um that relief is fully
funded by central
government um legislative changes also
allow for the changes to the council's
uh for the council tax empty in second
home charges um the levying of the
increased charges was previously
endorsed by members um and as I said the
policy appendix 2 provides a framework
for the administration of these changes
including mandatory exemptions but is
yet to be completely finalized um again
um Michelle as the head of revenues
benefits um is available if there's any
more detailed questions that members
would like answered thank
you uh members are there any questions
to the officer again just look at the
recommendations
here uh and let me just get to the
recommendations one second link you want
to just
think just here so uh we have the
recommendations again this is is to
council two
recommendations um if there are no
comments can we have a sent for
approval second oh it can be yes thank
you very much um thank you that is
agreed next item on the agenda well done
members next item on the agenda is the
treasury management strategy this is a
meeting of getting all these annual
things out the way to be found on pages
251 to
302 Miss Lucas
again thank you chair yes so the code of
practices for treasury management
requires the council to approve a
treasury management strategy before the
start of each Financial year and this
report fulfills the council's legal
obligation under the local government
acts to have regards to the chartered
Institute of Public Finance and
accountancy code so the sit for code
defines treasury management as the
management of the local authorities
borrowing investment and cash flows
including its banking money market and
Capital Market transactions and the
effective control of the risks
associated with those activities as well
as the pursuit of optimum performance
consistent with those
risks so in Broad terms The Authority is
required to operate a balanc revenue
budget each year which means that cash
raise during the year will roughly meet
its cash expenditure so part of the
treasury management function is to
ensure that cash flow is adequately
planned um with cash being a aable when
it's needed um as such any surplus
monies are invested with low-risk
counterparties which is commensurate
with the authorities current lowrisk
appetite um which ensures that we have
adequate liquidity before considering
any investment
return um the second main function of
the treasury Management Service is to
make sure we've got adequate funding for
the Authority's Capital plans and these
Capital plans provide a guides to any
borrowing need of the authority um to
enable us to do longer term cash flow
planning and make sure that we can make
make meet our
obligations um so in summary this report
sets out the council's potential
indicators as required by the code as
well as the external and local context
that the council operates within the
strategy has been reviewed by the
council's um treasury advisor link um
and also includes their latest interest
rates um projections and economic
Outlook which were current at the time
of writing the report in December
2023 um I'm happy to ask any answer any
questions members may have thank you
Council
white yeah my same old argument um on
appendix 2 we've got the capital spend
of 65,000 on a mower and a gator and I
did ask at the last meeting whether I
could get a breakdown or I was assured I
would get it but I haven't had it a
breakdown of the costs of the parks
department as a whole um because I think
we could do this for fraction of the
price by using contractors um I have
been asking for it about five years now
um and I still don't have it um because
65,000 on Machinery that's without
Manpower and wages and everything else
um so I'm going to stop you there
councelor white because that isn't
relevant actually to the treasury
management strategy it is a matter of
our procurement policy we have debated
that in the past so we're going to move
on from that I I note your question but
we but again that isn't in relation to
uh this agenda item any other
members councilor
bound going I just be pedantic on page
259 operational bank
accounts I think there's a wrong word in
printed the ccil May incurrent
operational Expos exposures for example
though I thought it' be through current
accounts not though well spotted Council
B you get tonight's gold
star uh for reading so members we have
one we have one recommendation members
we have one recommendation which is to
council which is to approve the treasury
management strategy a proposer please
councelor
white
theend and it's considerably milder
actually counselor white so perhaps
um so uh okay well we will rewind so
members uh need a proposal to approve
the treasury management strategy
councilor spencley seconded by councilor
Thompson all those in
favor thank you very much next item item
nine capital and investment strategies
for
2425 um please members and minimum
Revenue statement
2425 to be found on pages 30 thank you
303 to 242 M Lucas again
thank you chair so this report details
the intended capital expenditure plans
and funding Arrangements um for the year
ahead and sets presential indicators
against which actual expenditure and um
any borrowing should be monitored so the
capital strategy for 20242 is founded at
appendix one um and gives a high level
overview of how capital expenditure
financing and treasury management
activity contribute to the provision of
our local services along with an
overview of how that Associated risk is
managed um at appendix 2 there is the
capital project bids for the year ahead
um members should note that following
the discussion at strategy and resources
Committee in November um the item
relating to the Deni 100 um gym
extension and car parking has now been
removed but otherwise the capital bids
remain as considered by the committee in
November um appendix 3 sets out the
council's investment strategy for the
year ahead which which is um unchanged
from pre previous years um and appendix
4 sets out the minimum Revenue provision
statement which is required by the local
government acts
2003 um and the um dck communities um
sorry dck guidance on minimum Revenue
provision which is broadly to ensure
that capital expenditure is financed
over the period which is reasonbly
commensurate with the uh period in which
capital expenditure provides benefits to
the
council so these strategies have been
compiled um with the advice and support
again of the council's treasury advisor
link and the latest Outlook and interest
rate forecast at the time the strategies
were drafted um again happy to try and
answer any questions members may have
thank you members before you go
councelor white this committee agreed
our Capital program and that was
subsequently agreed by Council so we're
not going to revisit the parks and the
the capital we're not going to revisit
the capital program because that is this
is the strategy not individual items
that was agreed by this committee and
has been agreed by Council I'll let you
might ask your question though yes thank
you chairman I mean yeah okay we are
where we are but I've still not had a
response and I've been asking about five
years at the last meeting I was um
promised that I would get a report and
I've yet to get it your request has been
noted duly noted it was noted at the
last committee meeting okay thank you
members are there any other questions on
the Investments can you councelor stand
and I forgive me because I'm papered out
I've done two scrutiny committees at
County but what what is our forecast for
the interest rate going forward I was
quickly trying to is it
4% three sorry I'm trying to find it
please forgive
me sorry I just from link there's a lot
of paper lot of words here chairman and
I do
apologize I'm just just interested to
relying on Bank of England
forecast if you know councel if you can
forecast councelor stamp you can
no I'd like to compare it to things I
know other authorities are doing that's
all to find out if we're consistent well
not where consistent where we are is it
4% yeah so our we we're currently
projecting an average interest rate at
4% obviously it will um vary depending
on the type of investment but that that
is our um yeah base assumption um on
average over the year okay any other
questions members we have these uh four
recommendations again this is to go to
count
um next month can I have a proposer
please councelor Thompson seconder
councelor driver those in favor please
show those
against
abstentions well you haven't indicated
either way councelor stamp but I mean
they it's
fine okay that's noted thank you very
much
no we won't councilor F okay so that is
approved next item on the agenda
is
um item 10 2023 24 revised and
2425 original budget estimates again
miss
Lucas thank you chair so the purpose of
the report is um to note the um
provisional local government Finance
settlement which was announced by
government um on the 18th of December
2023 um also to present the um revised
budgets for The Current financial year
and the um proposed budgets for the next
financial year
2425 um and those are set out at
appendices 1 2 and three of the
report um the report also presents
options for the proposed level of
council tax increase increase for
20242 um which is proposed to be an
increase of
2.98% but that will obviously be subject
to approval at for Council um this would
mean an average bande council tax rate
of
27 which excludes the parish precepts
and that equates to um A6 um 52 increase
compared to the current Financial
year um further to that the report sets
out the policies on our designated use
of financial reserves which are set out
appendic
C4 um and also my statement on the
robustness of budgets and adequacy of
reserves which is found at appendix 5 um
lastly members should note the outcome
of the budget survey
2023 which is noted at appendix six um
so there's again quite a lot of detail
in the report but happy to answer any
questions thank you
members this is an important one are
there any questions councelor white
thank you Mr chairman uh yeah my
parishes um have had a problem with the
precept and they've not received the
money they were expecting um I
understand there was there was a problem
with the previous accounting I I don't
know what it is they've just asked me to
raise it as an issue and they said is
they going to be are the council going
to make up the shortfall that they've
got because it wasn't what they were
forecast to receive this was pearly
Parish Council uh they were quite badly
affected by it the others not so much in
my
ward um than through you chair oh yeah
please do thanks councelor white um yeah
there was um an issue which we wrote to
all parishes about um where there was a
a small calculation error in the
precepts for the previous year we did
make absolutely clear in the letter to
those all parishes that none of them
would be adversely affected so those
that would have um received um a
slightly higher amount in the previous
years we've offered to um compensate
them for the difference and those that
have actually benefited um we're not
seeking to claw those monies back so no
Parish Council will be adversely
affected but obviously it's regrettable
that error occurred thank you oh
brilliant thank you that's
good councilor Fluker you look like you
were about to just on the verge of
asking a question I could see that the
officers apologized over this and I know
it's affected quite a lot of Parish
councils but I mean why did this happen
happen I mean that's not my question but
I I I I I can see that others feel I
mean how did this happen bearing in mind
that we have these checks in place we
have our policies and procedures how
could this have
happened um yeah please do good question
yeah I mean it was just a a human era
that um yes say regressively wasn't
picked up at the time um we have
strengthened our checks and balances now
to make sure it doesn't happen again but
obviously it's quite a technical area um
of calculation so it's just um as I say
regretable that it wasn't picked up
earlier but it was it was just a genuine
human
error chairman if um if I can just come
back and ask the question I I I did
think that the the table on page 346
chairman was the way it was laid out was
a a tad mean um but I I I I know you
always welcome in an additional
allowance but it would appear that the
members uh area is going to cost 435,000
P clearly that's the sum total of the
column above but I think it would be
better laid out if you'd had a gap in
there and and unless of course and and I
know you all voted yourselves a pay rise
uh and I certainly didn't vote for it
myself but obviously you can see the
impact on that and uh and and and I hope
my friends enjoy their extra £12,000 and
you'll know already that I've said and I
already have done given it all to
charity thank you and then chairman just
looking at 3.6 point
six um chairman I it says his salar is
based on revised Council structure um
I've sort of looked at the number but
could you could
you ex expand on that so we've got
2425 pay rise you've set that at 5% and
I I sort of get that which generates a
cost 314,000
so uh I understand
increments but salaries based on revised
Council structure I wonder perhaps if
you could give us some more information
around
that yes M Lucas thank you yeah I mean I
think there just a a wording kind of um
issue if you like um all that means is
that obviously we break down the
salaries budgets um within the different
directorates of the council and
obviously there's been some change
internally particularly around Service
delivery in the year so the the detailed
budgets reflect the um lest Council
structure but overall um as you're aware
the um the the restructure of Service
delivery was um designed to be cost
neutral so there's no actual additional
pressure as a result of that it's just
the breakdown of the budgets internally
that's reflected here good thanks J if I
just come back so on
3.6.6 the second bullet it says
inflation ass assumptions minus 5%
average pay I I I think that's a hyphen
rather than a minus but clearly in the
wrong place and I know that that has
caused uh issues with some members of
Staff they who have seen this and they
think they're taking a cutting wages so
um yeah a human error I think you refer
to these things as thank you I I think
that's just a hyphen yeah so and I I
think all staff are well aware and we've
obviously given uh well um uh we have
given staff their pay award for this
year and they are aware that of our
assumptions for next next year so if any
one's got a misunderstanding about that
I'm more than happy to to have a
conversation thank you me councilor
white thanks for I was just looking down
I'm on page two of appendix
3 um and I was just curious I know
Heritage and
tourism um they're not really showing
any income unless I've got this wrong I
mean it is a bit of a way it's worded
but it doesn't look like they've they've
generated any
income yeah I say it might be me
misreading it it's a bit peculiar but I
thought the Heritage officer was going
to go out and do speeches and try and
gain an income and tourism well I
thought that was supposed to fund itself
and I I so unless I've read it wrong it
doesn't look like either of those two
have generated any income Miss Lucas if
you um yeah I think if there's um
questions on any detailed budget lines
then I think we'll need to take them
away because obviously I don't have all
of the detail of every single budget
line of the council at my immediate
disposal it may be that the income is
budgeted for separately but without as I
say having that detail I think would
need to come back to you with an answer
on that one thank you okay thank you
that is a biggie consider doing the um
any other question councelor
driver thank you chair um appendix six
the budget survey um it's just
observation really that it's
disappointing that we've got a survey
and quite a bit of work obviously has
got into this survey when we've got uh
75 responses so it's quite difficult to
make any real sensible judgments on the
basis of 75 responses I I accept that
actually you get what you get but I
think going forward it will I think we
need to put a bit more effort into
trying to increase increase the number
of responses uh to make it a bit more
meaningful yeah Council dri it was a
point made at the finance working group
but yeah it's a shame but we are worth
you one more time councilor
fluka can I refer you back to your
comment of full Council when you said
the time to ask questions was at this
meeting not full Council so if you'd
like all the questions at for Council
you can you can
have I'm pleased that the Chairman's
here this
my com because I think it's important
that all members are given the
opportunity to
coun just just for clarity and I I would
just say chairman um mindful of the fact
that there
are members uh that are colorblind
having a report that is red and green
isn't very helpful for them but chairman
I just wanted to go to appendix one on
uh page
355 um and just to make make sure I've
read this properly we will be using
£74,000 of the new homes budget new
homes bonus to prop up this budget have
I read that correctly M southman are
listening to you chair I Council Fluker
as we've previously discussed at a
number of meetings um the 474 is uh the
contribution to the council's budget for
this financial year which was agreed by
Council last February um in a similar
vein the new homes bonus allocation
which um in the provisional settlement
was set out as 495,000 um is equally
contributing to the general um Revenue
expenditure for the council um as
explained previously that is part of the
overall local government Finance
settlement and the expectation of
central government is that that funding
is used to um contribute to our overall
Revenue budget so thank
youa there are four people watching
YouTube one of those is me so much but
one I can you and I'll just get one is
in fact a well-known Hoster in jol good
jolly good thank you I just wanted to
pick up on the word that the1 officer
just used
expectation my understanding of the use
of the new homes B bonus from the
research I've done is is that it can be
used but it's not expected to be used
and a lot of councils don't use it some
do some don't but I don't think it's an
expectation of the government that you
lump it all together to prop your budget
I mean uh I mean if you've got a contra
viw I'd be happy to see that information
from the government where it says they
expect us to do thank you m
Lucas um yeah I think we have previously
shared the um the guidance around the
scheme when it as it was originally um
set out a number of years ago um but I I
have explained previously that when the
government publishes its core um
Financial um settlement and the core
spending power um and the headline
figures that it quotes across all local
authorities the assumption is that new
homes bonus is part of that core what
they call Core spending power so there
is that base assumption from government
that that the spending power of the
authority includes that amount obviously
there is a choice and you can choose to
use it for other things but that the the
base assumption is that that is part of
your core spending
power okay Council flug you're well
aware we we we are obl we due to our
position we are obliged to use our new
homes boners if we didn't use that to
prop up we would either have to make
Cuts or borrow to balance the budget I'm
afraid that's the simple fact of life
okay cancel or white thank you sorry
it's me again sorry I'm still I'm still
going to the park Countryside services
so we've got 141 is about a million and
a half and and it it brings in
1.4 Park ranges are about
470 odd th000 and brings in 400 from
what I could make
out uh and then we go down to oh gosh
this is really this is all over the
place yeah um parks and Open
Spaces it looks like it's about that
looks like it might make a profit but
then we don't know where that's come
from but but all I'd say is and it's
just a an a really difficult report to
make sense of and it would be nice on
this committee if we had a bit more of a
breakdown so we could actually see exact
where we were thank you m
Lucas uh thank you yeah I mean I note
your comments and it's always an ongoing
process to try and make sure that the
budgets are aligned properly to the
service activity and that they are as
transparent as possible um obviously the
budgets have evolved over a number of
years and there is a piece of work to
make um sure that as I say as part of
the um Service delivery restructure that
budgets are sitting in the correct place
and that that that information is as
transparent as I say as possible so I
take your comments on board and and um
yeah we will just try and improve them
in future thank you right members we got
one recommendation which is to council
consisting of uh sections a to e can I
have a proposal to agree approve those
please councelor Thompson do I have a
seconder councelor
Sidle uh thank you uh those in
favor thank you very much that is
carried and the next item on the agenda
is I I I it's carried
okay
noted it's
fine okay item 11 mtfs strategy 24 25 26
27 Miss Lucas
again thank you chair so this report
sets out the council's medium-term
financial strategy for the 3-year period
um spanning
20242 up until 2026
27 uh the detailed strategy is set out
at appendix one um and supports the
delivery of the council's objectives and
priorities as set out in its council's
corporate plan um within that appendix
there is a further three appendices um a
b and c which set out some of the
projections in more detail for both
revenue and capital and also set out the
council's policy on uh reserves and
balances
um so just in summary of the latest
position um on page 389 you will find
chart one which um shows in graphical
form the anticipated gap between our
future funding and
expenditure um for next year we are now
forecasting um a gap of
£11,000 um and that rises to £ 730,000
by the end of the mtfs
period uh there remains uncertainty
around the economic Outlook and the
impact that this will have on the
council's finances um and the potential
impacts on the council tax and business
rates and therefore we all need to keep
it under regular
review um I would also just like to note
that um further adjustments may still be
required um before approval by the
council subject to the outcome of the
final
20242 settlement which is expected in
early February and also the business
rates position for the council being
confirmed if there are any material
changes to the position presented
tonight that would be highlighted in the
council
papers um yeah I think that's all I say
there thank you chair members any
questions count lagen you look like you
about to no it's just um probably a
question you can't answer Miss Lucas but
it's um each year we sit here and look
at the the figures and the the midterm
financial situation and it the fluidity
it changes because just recently there
was a much bigger Gap and it was more
catastrophic in in its potential outcome
um and now it's slow it's it's lessened
so it's just really something that I
know you can't say yes I this is this is
going to be the factual part and it'll
fluctuate a tiny little bit but I just
get concerned that when we making
decisions on on Services Cuts
Investments Etc is this the best
information that we can base that
upon thank you all I will say before
Miss Lucas goes in it is the best
estimate I'm sure we live in volatile
times so if we could forecast things
that you know we we have uncertainty in
the Red Sea that could
significantly increase and produce
volatility certainly in the energy
Market again in which case a lot of
these figures are going to go out the
window but it is a best estimate and I'm
sure that's what Miss Lucas will
confirm thank you chair yeah obviously
in my role as section 151 officer I am
you know obliged to make sure that our
projections are as robust um as I can um
make them at the time of publishing the
report um obviously there is significant
um uncertainty particularly around um
things like the local government
financial Outlook but also wider
economic factors such as inflation and I
think at this point last year um there
was greater uncertainty around um
government's commitment to funding local
authorities um but also greater
uncertainty around the inflationary
impact and I think um throughout the
course of the year and um following the
peer review we've reviewed and refreshed
some of those assumptions particularly
around the ongoing Financial Outlook
from government um and also um as a
result of things like the waste contract
being um crystallized so we have more
certainty around the future cost of
those we've been able to bring some of
those cost assumptions down a bit which
has significantly improved the position
that we're reporting now um also there
has been work throughout the financial
year and with the um Finance member
group um to look at ways to close the
gap Gap um and also to minimize the
pressures so all of that work um is fed
into the latest position um and I did go
through at the informal briefing um a
week or so back with members um the
changes that have Arisen since the last
Financial year so um obviously there is
remains as I say uncertainty um and I
you know we don't know exactly what's
going to happen next year but based on
the information got at this time I'm
confident that that this is the position
that needs members need to
agree
councilor
s uh thank you chair yeah I one of the
things I would like to commend is is
Miss Lucas and her team for all the work
that they've done over the last year and
also for all the members of the the
finance working group as well I think
that's been really constructive and and
positive uh the I think the F the LGA
Finance peer review has been extremely
useful to the council in terms of
highlighting and working with with us
and the feedback from the LG a on Monday
was was that we are doing very well and
and their summary was very good in terms
of what we're doing we're in a much
better position than a lot of local
authorities in terms of our finances and
in terms of our reserves however in the
future years we've got more work to do
and we need to ensure that we don't rest
on our Laurels and that we ensure that
in the future you anything that we doing
in terms of you know the the savings
that we make fits with our corporate
strategy and I know councelor fluka we
police hear that um and one of the
things that we need to start doing as
soon as this uh budget is agreed in
February is start working on on those
future years um and to ensure that we're
all working together to ensure that the
the council remains financially
sustainable I think Council absolutely
um we're going to come to it in the next
agenda item under private and
confidential but you know for members
benefit the finance member group has
been meeting
fortnightly um and we have been
monitoring ing the constant changing
system the situation and bringing in the
costs of uh of the savings that have
been um proposed so um I'm very
confident in in answer to councelor
lagan's question that it's it's as good
as is possible to get in terms of an
estimate counselor stamp you had your
hand up first very high um rest assured
that all our MPS are lobbying government
central government to try and get fixed
term settlement because everybody
everybody in the country is saying how
how difficult it is to actually try and
you know stay afloat literally when they
don't know how much they're going to get
from from any grants from central
government uh it was discussed today at
Great length at County and everybody's
really trying to get some what's the
word Miss Lucas when it's like
consistency certainty certainty I knew
it began with the SE so hopefully that
will come forward no matter what color
or Creed if we have a general election
well the
the yeah we do we we we we know we know
yeah yeah councelor stamp you may be
aware that that there there is has been
another um not hand out from government
they don't do that but there has been
another major but I'm afraid our our
share of that is minis school it's
mainly gone to uper authorities with
social care responsibilities I think we
get £5,000 we something like that
yeah we should get something in that
about about about £5,000 thank you very
much um Chancellor councelor no that
you've got to be positive councelor
fluka let's go I'm positive now because
uh I I listen to the uh the um uh Shadow
local government Minister if there's
such a person he he thinks it's going to
be a good idea to means test all
councilors that don't deal with adult
and child's social carees but good luck
with that so I think councelor Lagan
asked a question about why we had such a
big figure and then it reduced I mean I
am correct I think in saying that two of
the main reasons for that was one was we
got a much better settlement than what
we were anticipating because we thought
we were going to get a a reduction and
the other was of course this
extraordinary amount of investment
income basically Bank interest now um
you know that fires a big warning shot
as far as I'm concern um particularly we
know there's going to be a change of
government um and that could that could
change the whole look Outlook on the
settlement it seems to me that there
seems to be a mood to put a huge amount
of money into adult and child social
care and it has to come from somewhere
um so I think realistically that made a
big difference to where we were um but
if you were if you were to strip out the
the interest and and we can debate all
evening about where interest rates will
be in two years's time um price water
house have a completely different view
to our uh advisors and I know advice is
only advice but I think it's sometimes
it's very very important for for A1
officer to look at this advice and think
well what happens if it goes the other
way um and and there isn't anything out
there and it would have been nice to to
look at this and and say well okay well
if the interest trates if the interest
rates drop away as some of the major
financial institutions are suggesting
including the national Westminster bank
if one goes online today you'll notice
that the investment short-term
Investments now are 2% lower than what
they were 6 months ago and you probably
noticed that yourself so there is
something in the marketplace and and
it's it's very dangerous sometimes just
to go to one particular source of
information and you know we've we've had
this before um so and and then just very
briefly chairman the the leader mentions
resting on laws well the time to have
sorted this all out really probably
would have been 6 months ago we were
look looking at a huge gap in our budget
we were only saved by investment income
and the settlement not changing had that
have not been the case we would probably
be looking closer to1 1.2 million and I
think at the moment we're trying to
close a budget down to a deficit of 150
which had it have been the other way
around we would have had a deficit of
600,000 but perhaps we can debate that
more when we talk about the hard work of
this Finance group in the next meeting I
know it's difficult chairman I don't
think it's challenging enough in summary
that I don't think it's challenging
enough but that's I'll let Miss Lucas
come in I mean the only point I'd make
our increased um interest has
been yes I know but it Al also has the
inflationary uh inflation impact on a
lot of our costs so most of that has
been eaten up regrettably but miss Lucas
thank you chair um just to provide some
Assurance to counselor fluka um yeah the
interest rate forecast that we used
obviously a link is our our um provider
but they do take on board a range of
other views including those of capital
economics in terms of coming up with
their views so it's not just the view of
of one individual they take a view
across the market and come up with their
interest rate projections the interest
rate that's built into our future mtfs
reflects the um uh the interest rates um
that are projected to fall over the
course of that period so we're not fully
um assuming that the interest rates as
they currently are will continue it's
based on on those um future interest
rates coming down and that in part
contributes to the growing Gap um which
is um shown in the report um also just
to assure members that um table 8 sorry
paragraph 8.4 on page 403 there is some
sensitivity scenarios around um the
interest rate projections so you can see
what 0.5% um drop in investment um rates
would mean to us as a council which is
in the order of £125,000
so um the particular point the council
fluka raised around not being clear
about the impact of the interest rates
is actually addressed within within the
strategy thank you only to that only but
only to that BPS and it's a very small
BPS that you're quoting there and I mean
I know this is hugely difficult but for
members to poply understand this you
need to well I would ask you to consider
in future extending out the BPS so
members can really truly understand I
mean on the plus side of this and and I
think chairman you just said we could be
at war in three three fronts in 12
months time and we know what happens
then so um I think sometimes it it's
good just to give a little bit more
because of the volatility of the market
and also the other way so it's not just
down councilor fugy I mean you make an
extremely good point and you know I
would remind you there are there are
people that make an awful lot of money
gambling on the interest rates uh so you
know that we have to rely on our you
know the best advice that we have but
the other point you make which is
extremely valid particularly this
evening is that yes we are only looking
at a
150,000 Gap but that could increase
significantly which places even more
importance on us achieving the savings
that we're going to talk about later not
only this year but in subsequent years
so I thank you for that comment
councelor
spenley thank you chair um I think it's
the mark of a good CFO that for at least
nine months of the year they project
quite a bleak picture of the future and
uh pour a bit of rain on the mitigating
factors um and I'm not saying we're out
of the woods by any means but I I just
want to say I'm very grateful for the
Prudence that's been displayed and for
the way members have worked together on
this situation uh this this problem and
and it's a very very complex future as a
number of people have said but there are
authorities out there that take a kind
of deenan something will turn up View
and are getting into very deep trouble
uh so as I say I'm very grateful that
we've taken this approach and I hope
we'll continue to work together thank
you councelor spencley right okay I
think we've done this one members so we
have uh recommendation
one uh thank councelor white thank you
sorry I thought you s my hand earlier
but never mind no I was just going to
say that um you know I think this is a
really good place where we are and I
know there's been certain members that
have wanted to pretty much abolish more
than District Council because everybody
kept saying we were financially unsound
it was unviable but yeah I'm not going
to not going to mention names and and I
have say I've always said that we're a
good authority we manage our district
well um I love the area planning
committees because we listen to the
local people and I've always said we
were we we were a good authority and
what's interesting is all the ones we
were meant to Revere which was thork and
Cen and S and all these other other
councils they're all in they're all done
they're all bankrupt you know so I have
to say Well done to everybody at molden
District Council for hanging on together
and I think we do need a pat on the back
I mean I'm I'm a bit worried what's
going to happen with Devolution and I
suspect that's not going to be good for
us but um with what I'm hearing um so I
certainly don't support that but we we
haven't really got any say in it
unfortunately and but just say we're a
good authority we've done well and let's
stick at it thank you it's it's a point
well made councelor white but the Gap
increases and the Gap thank you Council
Fluker the Gap will increase to such a
level that we won't be sustainable
unless we achieve the cuts uh and make
the changes that we I'm sorry we will
have used our reserves um we don't make
the cuts we're Authority that's not good
at making Cuts well then we won't
survive anyway right thank you very much
indeed members um can I have a proposal
for the recommendations as shown
councelor Thompson seconded by councelor
bound please show those in favor thank
you very much indeed well done
members right
uh right uh next I of any items of
business the chairperson's decide are
Urgent there are none we
now you can we'll let we'll have a
comfort break then yes councelor stamp
would you mind and I'm going to say this
in open um ESS C ccel provide me with
paper copies I'm get going to get upset
my eyes are killing me looking at this
screen they really are you should
provide paper copies to people with
difficulty with their
eyes sorry I don't know how you get
paper copies because they give it to me
because I strug this is really killing
my eyes I I don't get paper copies so no
but you your I do oh okay well perhaps
we could look at that if somebody has
that particular problem
and also for those that are color blind
I'm not sure how many um there you are
apparently you can apply for a
dispensation counselor stamp I've just
had a message from than Miss bird and if
you wish to have them printed you can do
so thank you what
dispensation what oh seriously my eyes
are really really hurting okay we are
still in public session members so yeah
okay perhaps you should have what we
should carry on I mean it's the col
going to halfway through the nextend
itend it we will wait for councelor
Sidle
please really we are going into PNC we
are going into PNC
so can I just clarify are you joury at
the moment no not at the moment you're
still it's about to come in the door
councel white and there was absolutely
nothing to be achieved by adjourning it
right next item exclusion of the public
and
press that under section4 of the Local
Government Act 1972 the public be
excluded for the from the meeting for
the following items of business on the
ground that it involves lightly
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph 3 of part one
schedule 12a to the ACT and this
satisfies the public interest interest
test I say move do I have a second
councelor Thompson those in favor
thank you right thank you
members